how do you die nick swords and how do
you die we ask a lot of our guests out
here
a lot of people we don't have guests
that we have just [ __ ] hard that pass
through
um how would i die i don't know maybe i
would want to like
i'd want to go out you know what i mean
like i'm
you know i would want to like crowd surf
in my 90s
you know what i mean that like a [ __ ]
creed reunion oh yeah
yeah and they're singing like can you
take me higher
and i'm 90. i can barely [ __ ] do it
i've take the wheels off my body
yeah and then just have him throw me and
then while i'm in the air i'd
shoot heroin into my eyes
i see something a little bit more
engaging for you though man
for i'm just let it rip man i feel like
i see you driving like a party bus
of [ __ ] youngsters that are out for
their first prom you know
and they're and all they have is a
little bit of bush light but you [ __ ]
just just limpy leave a [ __ ] sack of
of cocaine back there for the [ __ ]
kid yeah or just you know like passive
aggressively
right like like roll the window down and
just kind of like pretend like it flew
in the window
right and so then the party gets [ __ ]
buck you know
you have to bring other people into my
[ __ ] demo so
this is how i'm dying that's how you die
so then all right well they're
guardian bro they're going hard and you
start to get a little bit jealous
because you're just the driver dude you
know what i'm saying you're just
cruising a group of people over to a
shitty [ __ ]
almost closed tj ribs right
and you're cruising over there and
finally you can't take it anymore you
pull over onto the side of the
interstate you know
and you start partying with them doing
beer bongs butt beer bongs all of them
the big hitters you know
right it's really showing off you know
some people are scared but some people
are still engaged but thankfully
you guys are in a zone where their
phones don't quite work right
right you were supposed to pull like
over all the way outside of a tunnel but
you stayed in the tunnel a little bit
because you guys are in new jersey
and next thing you know bro you guys are
now this makes sense you guys are living
high on the [ __ ] hug and like
some boy and girl are both losing their
virginity and
you know in par and things that didn't
even know was going on dude
right and finally a [ __ ] semi truck
carrying fresh meats and produce just
[ __ ]
grills you guys bro and sends y'all all
y'all to heaven as a group
oh okay i like the end yeah we're all
just unified and then
do does my heaven body go back to like
how i look now
like like like i'm at a prom and [ __ ]
key west yeah
everybody does dude yeah yeah everybody
it looks like yeah you look like a
sherpa of the three flights of stairs
in [ __ ] canker
that's perfect i kind of like that my
side death was
a bit i read that went viral that was
amazing about the trapeze artist with
diarrhea oh yeah
dude that'd be a good way to go out too
just get up there
just crush like three days of t-bell
yeah maybe a [ __ ]
then i have like a peanut butter
broccoli smoothie
and pour it in an omelette with eggs
that are old rotten
yeah and then chug that but then also
lay in a hot like soak in a sauna for a
little bit so your body's real supple
you know what i'm saying
yeah it's just to go yeah you have two
percent chance of holding in
a [ __ ] warm pot of d yeah the hot pot
and then just some [ __ ] scalding
ovaltine i
grab i grab the [ __ ] trapeze
[ __ ] bar i look at a picture of brian
callan
and i'm ready to go i set it off
yeah on the world stage new year's eve
new year's eve and kathy griffin's down
there with her mouth open
kathy griffin's reporting and then it's
just
game on
so that's another option there's a lot
of options good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one ah